foreign America
there are decisions that we are asked to
make in our lifetimes that are truly
homely
inside that building right now the
powers that be are negotiating your
future decisions than in previous times
would have been left to the gods but you
can't negotiate with a fighter or a
flood or a family
we must save ourselves
extrapolations has sort of an
interesting origin story after I was
involved in the making of An
Inconvenient Truth one of the questions
that I asked myself was as a Storyteller
how do we take the science and move it
into more conventional scripted
storytelling in episode one we really
established
styles of the world
the pretty unsafe place to live in
[Music]
anytime you're looking into the future
you're asked to make some speculations
how's the world going to look what's
going to change it's an enormous theme
played on an enormous stage with very
personal small stories which is why I
think it's so relatable
the shows that pretend that the climate
is going to be the same in 10 or 15
years those are the science fiction
shows because the climate is changing
the nature of the show lends itself to
really not being able to know what
you're going to get the Cliffhangers
aren't for the immediate moment after
it's for what's gonna happen in five
years
my family's never leaving you know we
would come and hear you speak even if we
had to tread water the entire time
so that's a comforting thought it's very
Vivid one of the great things about the
stories in here is that it manages to
shrink them down to small personal
moments the cost is huge
the first person I spoke to was Meryl
she read the script and said okay when
are we doing this
Sienna Miller was so excited to play
Meryl Streep's daughter you want me to
read for a while no no no I'm
you're going to be here I'm not your
Shahidi is very powerful our enough is
spectacular Edward Norton is about as
passionate and as eloquent a person as
I've ever met Gemma Chan tahar raheen
Diane Lane Toby Maguire eats Gonzalez
Forest Whitaker Marianne kotiar and kit
kit Harrington is sort of the connective
tissue in this entire series good
evening
good evening people can find every
emotion in it including hope I think the
way that you find comfort is in
imagining yourself in the positions that
our characters are in we're not gods
people are entertained I certainly am
the scripts are beautifully shot there's
jokes like it's funny
the show ultimately every episode is
about people finding each other people
finding ways to team up new friends
fellow citizens and they can find a way
to work together